the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones and
house of the dragon video
all right my friends i have some new
information i would like to discuss
in this video there is a website that
has been releasing a lot of exclusive
information about the new game of
thrones series
as of right now none of this has been
confirmed by hbo but they might make an
official announcement
in the following days i say that because
i can almost guarantee we will see
these characters in the show considering
house of the dragon will be about the
dance of dragons
the illuminati has further news on which
new characters of westeros will be seen
in the new
show a number of characters from george
rr martin's book fire and blood
have been rumored to star in the
upcoming series house of the dragon
the illuminati can confirm that rhaenyra
targaryen
alison hightower and coloris velaryon
will all have
series regular billings on the show
considering has already been hired as
king viserys targaryen and we have
reported that matt smith is being looked
at for the role of his brother daemon
targaryen
we can also report that four more
characters from fire and blood will be
included
in this house of the dragon adaptation
of the targaryen dynasty
these four new characters are sir
christian cole
messaria reynese targaryen and harold
westerling
now if you're not familiar with these
characters i will give you some of their
background information they have listed
here
sir kristin cole would be a series
regular meaning he would be someone we
would see
throughout many seasons of the show they
are looking for an actor who is middle
eastern or
mediterranean he's ruggedly handsome the
soul of knighthood
and chivalry and a capable warrior he is
a member of viserys targaryen's
kingsguard but later on he does become
the lord commander of the kingsguard
now if you really want to learn what
these new characters will do in house of
the dragon i would highly recommend
watching one of my more recent videos
where i explain the main story of this
series
i basically go over all the major events
that will be seen
i will link that video down below the
next character masaria
is a very interesting one if i do say so
myself
she is sort of like the female version
of a varys or littlefinger
so i'm very excited to see what they do
with her she will also be a series
regular
lady misery is a striver and a schemer
she seeks to rise up in a society that
sees her as an outcast
and an outsider her beginnings are as a
sex worker
but she never lets an opportunity slide
and her intelligence and unflagging
ambition will carry her even nearer to
her goal
she wants to have power over the power
full now
it remains to be seen whether she will
use it to gain acceptance or revenge
life in westeros is a game and she wants
to win it
that sounds exactly like a character we
already know in fact
you will notice that a lot most of these
characters are very similar to some of
the characters we have already seen
in game of thrones she is also known for
having a relationship with king viserys
targaryen's brother daemon
so we will most likely see a lot of her
in house of the dragon
the next character on this list is
rhaenys targaryen
who will also be a series regular it
says she is wise and cultured
the queen who never was she was passed
over for the iron throne simply because
she wasn't a man
she is clever capable spirited and proud
she is the embodiment of grit and grace
and
is utterly fearless she is also a dragon
rider
she is split between her loyalty to her
husband
and her own feminist aspirations and
disappointments
she struggles with supporting the claim
of the princess
a younger but wilder version of her own
self
who stands to inherit the seven kingdoms
she is a feminist
but also a realist she harbors doubt
that the princess will make a capable
ruler
this character rhaenys has one of the
most epic dragon battles during the
dance of dragons
while on her dragon she fights king
aegon
and his brother aemond while they're on
their own dragons
rhaenys does die during this dragon
fight but not before
severely injuring the king aegon who
never fully recovers from this attack
dragon fought dragons and a second sun
blossomed in the sky when the smoke
cleared
only eamond and vegar stood uninjured
sunfire the most
magnificent dragon in the world had one
of its wings almost completely torn from
its body
trapped beneath sunfire was the king
himself broken and burned so badly in
places that his armor had fused onto his
flesh
again if you want to learn more about
this then i would recommend watching my
other video down below
now the last character on this list is
harold westerling
it says he will be a series regular but
i doubt he will be on the show
as much of the other characters
mentioned he was the lore commander of
the kingsguard
under viserys targaryen in fact it says
he was one of the longest serving
members of the kingsguard
who also had a very successful military
background
there isn't a whole lot of information
on this character
i think the series will focus more on
sir kristin cole
who becomes the lord commander of the
kingsguard after harold westerling
i think that makes more sense because
sir christian cole is there during the
dance of dragons
and he's heavily involved in a lot of
the battles
as i said before this information has
not been confirmed by hbo but i would
almost guarantee we will get an official
announcement soon
these characters influence a lot of the
events during the dance of dragons so we
will have to see them in the new show
in my opinion you cannot do house of the
dragon without them
this news actually has me very excited
because now we get an even better idea
of what we can expect to see the dance
of dragons is one of the most amazing
moments in all of a song of ice and fire
as long as
hbo does a faithful adaptation of this
source material
there's no reason why this show won't be
another massive success like game of
thrones
it already has all those ingredients
that made game of thrones so great
the only thing it's really missing is
the white walkers but they were mostly
off screen
or in the background anyways i think
they will certainly make up for that
with the amount of dragons this series
will have
i'll say it again i'm very excited about
what this show may bring
now that i know it will be about the
dance of dragons
i'm really looking forward to seeing
this brought to life on the screen
make sure you subscribe because i will
be making videos whenever new
information regarding house of the
dragon is released
as soon as filming begins within the
next few months i will be making videos
almost every day because that's when
things really start leaking out from the
set
so if you're interested in seeing all
that then make sure you stick around for
a while
exciting things are finally starting to
happen with the new show and i for one
cannot wait
as always i want to thank everyone for
watching my video
i hope you're here for the next one have
a great day everyone
i will see you again very soon bye
you